Group of Seven Summit has now wrapped up
in Japan with leaders pledging more
support for Ukraine's war with Russia so
the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski and the Japanese prime
minister fumio kishida there they are
they laid wreaths at the Hiroshima Peace
Memorial and zelenski compared Japan's
rebuilding of the city that was
devastated by a nuclear bomb to his
hopes for war-torn Ukraine then there
was the U.S President Joe Biden who
reaffirmed his support for Kiev
unveiling a 375 million dollar military
aid package to bolster Ukraine's
defenses on Saturday Russia claimed
victory in the Ukrainian city of bakmuts
president zielinski said his troops are
still fighting
I cannot share it with you the Tactical
views of our military of our Warriors
but as of today we can see that the
country which is a dozen times bigger
than we are cannot occupy us cannot win
this war and we understand that a bit
more and then we will be prevailing and
that is why we are acting how we are
acting valuing the lives of people the
hardest is if backmot had some military
tactical mistake for instance and people
could be surrounded then all the
military know what could happen how we
could create the situation for people
not to be captured now our people are
accomplishing a very simple Mission they
are now in bakmut I will not share where
exactly but eyewitnesses say that bakman
is not occupied by the Russian
Federation as of today
okay we have Natasha Butler there she is
in a moment we'll bring in Natasha she's
standing by with a reaction from Kiev
but first let's bring in rock McBride
who's joining us from the summit venue
in Hiroshima well the summit has now
ended Rob we heard from several leaders
today including President Biden and
president zielinski just give us the
highlights and tell us what they have to
say
foreign
leaves this G7 having been able to meet
in person often for the first time and
engage with many more world leaders from
countries that have either been remained
neutral or have quite close links to
Russia there's a long list of countries
that have come along to this G7 but
quite a significant influential
countries such as Indonesia Brazil uh
India and of course he has able been
able to reconfirm reconnect with the G7
his big support is there which in turn
has come out and declaring its
unwavering uh commitment to Ukraine this
was repeated by fumi okashida the host
Japanese prime minister in his closing
Address given fittingly in the Hiroshima
Memorial peace Park which commemorates
the atomic attack in 1945 calling out
Russia for its aggression against
Ukraine and also attacking Russia for
its threat to use nuclear weapons which
people here in Japan almost universally
regard with an absolute abundance
zelenski is very good at connecting with
host Nations and audiences wherever he
is in the world and as he did again here
saying that he was struck going around
the museum to the Hiroshima Atomic
attack at the heart of the scenes of
Carnage Endeavors Devastation he is
witnessed in Ukrainian Towns at man
cities a tortured Wasteland as he put it
but just as Hiroshima has rebuilt he
promised that Ukraine would rebuild but
with the Grim caveat that will only come
with peace peace will only come he says
after Russia has been defeated on the
battlefield okay Rob stand by for just a
moment because I'd like to bring in
Natasha Butler to just clarify the
situation for us in Bahamut Natasha
because when zelenski was speaking at
the G7 he said that his troops are still
fighting there the Russians say they
claim victory what's going on
well it's a confused picture it often is
the case with uh back the situation
there that has been grinding on that
battle grinding on for so uh many months
what we have here is claim and
counterclaim on Saturday the boss of the
Wagner Russian mercenary group said that
his forces were in full control of
bakmut well that was uh quickly refuted
uh by authorities here in Kiev we then
heard there uh the Ukrainian president
of Vladimir zielinski saying that
Ukrainian troops are still fighting are
still in bakmut well we have had uh some
uh updates from Ukraine's military the
commander of Ukraine's Ground Forces
Alexander siski he says that the
situation on the ground is difficult but
it is under control he says Ukrainian
forces do control a very small part of
the city but enough he says to allow
those forces to enter the city if they
would need to uh rather cryptically he
said that the situation could probably
change he also said that Ukrainian
forces had made some uh gains on the
flanks on the suburbs of back mode so
that's the picture from the commander of
Ukraine's military forces uh on the
ground but as I said of course what we
do know the big picture is this battle
has been going on now between Russian
Ukrainian forces for 10 months many
lives lost on both sides okay thank you
Natasha we'll let you go for now that's
our Natasha Butler reporting for us from
Kevin we'll once again cross over to
Hiroshima and Japan Rob McBride is there
because Rob uh the other big item on the
agenda of course was China so uh well
tell us what happened there
yeah this G7 has seen uh the the G7 come
together in a united front uh against
China we heard in Joe Biden the U.S
president his closing uh Speech and
press conference saying he doesn't want
to decouple from China that would simply
be uh in impossible to do with the West
uh the G7 and China need to engage on
things like the global economy on
unshared interest like tackling climate
change but what he stressed was he
wanted the G7 to de-risk from China by
that he means the U.S and its allies
protecting things like strategically
sensitive Supply chains in in things
like Advanced semiconductor production
which he says China has misused in the
past in things like weapons production
well he says that the G7 will take a
stand against that and in their
communique they outline a whole host of
alleged malign Behavior by China and
when it comes to the global economy and
conducting what they call economic a
coercion military expansionism threats
to Taiwan also a lack of transparency in
the development of its nuclear Arsenal
saying that just as the G7 is united in
support of Ukraine so they have never
been more united when it comes to taking
a stand against China China for its part
very quickly has hit back calling the G7
a small group which itself is a threat
to peace and stability so a lot from
this G7 to annoy and irk both China and
Russia thank you Rob McBride reporting
for us from Hiroshima Japan so as